[Music]
you are interested in playing if they
ever make a movie about she-hulk oh no I
see hope she hope got my move for next
time what's going on down there
but you're interested in playing shiho
now she hook is the cousin of the Hulk
she's yeah we have a I think we have a
picture of yes look at her yes she is so
slammin I can't oh my god she's
incredible she's amazing I can't so you
got a place she yes you know it just
started very innocently as like a thing
on Twitter and you know it just and then
it sort of went viral and then at our
TNT lunch and thing you know where they
do that thing where they put us around
reporters yeah and they give us alcohol
not good
so that's when you started saying I want
to play she got really excited and fired
up about it and you know I probably
shouldn't have had that second glass of
champagne before I started talking about
her and it would got to just be a whole
thing about 36 CS and how awesome she is
and her giant libido does she Hulk have
a I don't know I have to say I don't
know much about she-hulk no well you
brought it up we're talking about
she-hulk has large breasts and she has a
healthy libido is that right well yeah
yes yeah
but they I mean think about laying by
that well I'm not promoting you know
[ __ ] ism I'm not saying
lassy sweat isms light ism yes this
[Laughter]
she's a little you saying that she okay
just go with me for a second okay so if
you were to be a superhero that was a
woman this one just happens you know to
have slept with her but like Captain
America and Iron Man and Superman in
play and she says all these guys yes
really yes
in the comic eleven-year-old Tommy Lee
[Applause]
god there's just something very you know
I want to see this I want to see you
play this you know and I think I know a
good Captain America
[Applause]
man I can't wait for the next Turner
event we're real tight on 10th but we
have a clip here from Rizzoli and Isles
that we wanted to get to anything we
need to know for this nope I don't
believe he or she Hulk in this clip
let's take a look okay oh my god you're
sure Lydia Lydia dad's fiancee Lydia
yeah yeah I saw her name on the parking
notices Lydia sparks and you're sure
she's pregnant she's out to here how the
hell should I know
well should we go pop she says he dumped
her do we just not know him or is he
having some deranged late midlife crisis
Jenny she's living out of her car
what if that's a my brother or sister oh
my god Rizzoli and Isles airs Tuesdays
at 9:00 on TNT she-hulk is coming out in
one year I am the executive producer
I'm also the director and I play every
male